well that's what Labour's say I think  they might be buying themselves a little  more time here and kiss Dharma the  shadow brexit secretary told Sophie  Ridge on Sunday a couple of weeks ago  that it would be inevitable that a  confidence vote would be called if  Teresa may couldn't pass this vote as  mrs. may arriving now at the  chancellor's office some of them call it  the washing machine because of the  modern architecture there and waiting  for her Angela Merkel who's been flying  the Union Jack the German national flag  and the European Union flag in  anticipation of this myth a visit Angela  Merkel of course has now stood down as  leader of her party the CDU but says she  plans on staying on as Chancellor until  the next federal elections in Germany